[Music]
to share my insights from a book that
I've just finished reading I made the
short version of this for Instagram but
I wanted to just go into a bit more
because I think that I think it can help
a lot of people so it's definitely
helped me and yeah I just wanted to
wanted to share that so the book
five-second rule by Mel Robbins she's
got a really really cool TED talk which
I'll put a link in the in the
description so you can do that and
basically they're not some bolts of this
book because there's always one sort of
key message normally in books and it's
what the title is so I've been trying to
the last sort of 2-3 weeks now and it's
definitely definitely work so I'm
someone who I go to the gym before
before work and when I get up I'd be
lying if I just go out there
straightaway I'm a normal human being
when that alarm goes off sometimes I'm
thinking not today not today and so the
last three weeks is a simple technique
and basically you count down from five
so soon as you get down to one you get
outta bed you do the thing that you're
trying to do and it works is so so
simple and it just sound it just sounds
so simple but try it and it works and
the amazing thing in she breaks it down
in this book there's a lot of science
behind it in terms of when you count
down the activate it's a different part
of your brain so it gets the thinking
pushed aside and you just take action
and you can apply it in all areas of
life which I really liked and that
that's what I think is just amazing them
about it so if you're you have that sort
of instant feel to sort of maybe go out
to Australia and talk to them but and
then your mind gets into working on I
don't you don't like a Wally or whatever
count down from five and just do it and
it's when you stop walking over there
then you'll you'll see what happens but
it's listening to that sort of gut
instinct of actually just just doing it
and not letting the mind get in the way
because their minds and I've been there
myself and you
to deal with it on a daily basis you'll
think yeah I'm gonna go do this but then
your mind will get in the way and be
like no you're not gonna do that
and this five-second rule is simple such
a simple technique really eliminates
that and I'd really encourage people to
try it particularly with getting up in
the morning if you I find that if you're
if you really get on with getting up
early and sort of changing your morning
routine or change it to something that
you've been thinking about I wish I
could get up a bit earlier doing this or
whatever then there's every chance that
you're gonna build on that so really
cool book five-second rule
Mel Robbins I definitely definitely
recommend reading it and as I said I'll
put the link to her TED talk on in the
description so hopefully one person will
read that and it will help them so
[Music]